Hình thành giống nhìn chính là nên tàng để Việt Nam phát triển mạnh mẹ hơn trong thị kiếp tọn cầu hã,
và việc phát quy vàn ngoá giống nhé sẽ giúp giống nhé Việt tạo dức bản sắc dương,
nân cào vị thế trên trực của thế.
Đó là thung biệt được đưa ra trong ngày giám ất chương trình con đường giống nhé,
bản lính và khá bảo vừa tu trích tại Hanoi.
Này chỉ là một trong nhiều sự kiệt trong gì pin nhận ngày giống nhìn Việt Nam mới bà thứng mở.
Những hод lượng thiết thực nó tiếp tục khẳng định vài trong tiên phong trong phát triển kinh tế xa hội,
gốc phần quan trọng vào sinh nghiệp công nghiệp hoa hiện đại hóa đất nước.
Tính từ đầu năm tới này,
cả nước có hơn 2 chăm bà mút nghiệm dây nghiệp lãnh kí thình lập mới và quay trở lại hòn đọc,
tăng hơn 2-2-3 sống phần chăm số với cùng kỳ.
Tổng số vốn tăng thêm hơn 3-3 phép bà trực tì đọng.
cả nước hiện có khoảng 1 triệu dây nghiệp đàn hòn đọc.
Tự nhiễm tập loàn lượng vườn dạ thế giới,
đến hàng triệu dây nghiệp nhỏ vào vừa đăng bên bị mỗi ngày trên thị trường trong nước,
tất cả đụi vọc phần làm nên một dịch mọng mới trên đình kinh tế Việt Nam,
năng đọc, lùi mới và đầy khách vọng.
Dịch làm con những bước tiến đánh tử hào trên bại sách hạnh rối mới xánh tạo cảnh cầu giai.
Chúng ta đứng hạn mang bị sấu về đầu ra,
nhưng vẫn còn tục khẩu ở hạn năm bị bà về đầu bà.
Từ thể chết, nhung lực cho đến hạt tần.
Về điều đó cho thấy tìm năng xánh tạo của người vì lại rất mạnh,
nếu chúng ta quyết địa khơi thông,
những điểm nghỉn, mạnh tính hệ thống nưu trần.
Từ những nhật đến nay, đối mới xánh tạo tuy nhiên cầu ma chủ cầu.
Thuy nhất là tài chính đủ mạnh, thứ 2 là lãnh đạo đúng tầm.
Và thứ 3 là hệ xin thấy đủ rộng để lên tỏa.
Nhìn sang những nước như là chúng quốc thì có những tập đoàn,
đời bật như là Fox Còn Hé Lắc Xea,
thì họ cũng đầu từ việc giác công lấp giác rất là đất giả.
Tuy nhiên thì nhờ sự khó trợ từ chính phụ,
thì hệ này họ đã vinh lên thành những nhà sản xuất.
Thì bị gốc, hành đầu thì giới,
với giác chiếc của nhoa hành trục cái đô la hành trăm thì đối mới.
Bởi vậy, tuy ti rằng không chỉ chúng tôi mà tất cả các duyên nghiệp Việt Nam khác,
đều có khăn vọng máy liền để bất phá trong khi quyền quyền quyền quyền của rất tập.
Trong thư, người dưới công thường các đầy tảm người nằm,
chúng tự vô tri mên từng cần giận,
đoàn kết thường yêu, giúp đỡ nhau cũng kếm bộ.
Hôm nay, tình thành ở ý được những mạnh trong cảm kết của chính phụ,
về liêm chính, kính tạo, hành động, phục vụ dân nghiệp và dân nghiệp.
Đây nghiệp.
Dưới nhân hai vần vý tế thuy dân.
Một động được quan trong nhất,
đều ký tế.
Anh không da.
Với có phần s אל dân nghiệp,
giới sẽ trường để giới giới sự lấy đảo của đảy hằng.
Sự quan lý của nhân l vier người,
ăn sức làm chỗ của nhân dân.
Với thình thần tiên phòng Khát vọng hội nhập,
và chiếc tội Việt Nam,
cũng dòng sinh nghiệp dân nghiệp hôm nay sẽ tiếp tục viết đến hành trình từ Hào,
hành trình của một Việt Nam vương xa trong khi,
Vinh Bói.